Allah says in surah Imran chapter number
3 verse number 195
never will I suffer the loss of any of
you
be it a male or a female
your partners unto one another that
means just because you're a male or a
female man or a woman Allah will not
suffer any loss that you do any work
that you do
I started this talk
by reciting a verse of the Quran from
Surah Alimran chapter number three.
From Surah Azab chapter number 33 verse
number 35 where Allah says
for Muslim men and Muslim women
for believing men and believing women
for devout men and devout women.
for true men and true women.
For men and women who are patient and
constant.
For men and women who humble themselves
in prayers.
For men and women who give charity,
for men and women who fast and deny
themselves,
for men and women who protect and guard
their chastity,
for men and women who engage much in
Allah's prais
for them. Allah has prepared
forgiveness and a great reward. Here
Allah is talking about all the various
types
for Muslim men and women, for believing
men and women, for true men and women,
for deed men and women, for men and
women who are patient and constantly.
For men and women who humble and pray,
for men and women who give in charity,
for men and women who fast. For men and
women who guard their modesty, for men
and women WHO PRAISE ALLAH, ALL OF them
Allah has given forgiveness and have
prepared ample reward. That means
spiritually and in other aspects men and
women are equal.
This is
the true and practical gender equality
and Islamic solution.
Let's discuss
the economic rights of women in Islam.
Islam
gave women economic rights 1,250
years before the western world. In
Islam, 1400 years ago,
an adult woman could possess property.
She could own or even dispose her
property
without
the consent of the husband.
The first time
in England in the western world in 1870s
under the Married woman property act
a western woman was allowed to own,
possess or dispose of property without
the permission of husband.
And this act was later revised in 1882
and again in 1887.
So what the western women got their
rights
hardly 150 years ago, Islam has given
1,400 years ago. 1,250
years before the Western